clean how many screenplays have you sold
sold sold I would say maybe five okay
fine
yeah so something like that uh I don't I
think only two of them have been made
though you know I mean like normally I'm
hired to write something and then it it
gets produced that way where they have a
very specific plan for what's going to
happen to it yeah very few syv got specs
that are out there all over the place
you know they just float around and I've
got this great I think it's great script
I that I really love about rodeo I've
got this other script about politics
kind of like a Casablanca set in
politics and like they both been out
there and people love them and they just
kind of float waiting for you know
lightning to strike and the movie to
take off well how did you sell your
first screenplay dumb dumb luck I think
I think as far as selling goes I think
you would count manic as a sell because
Michael Bacall and I wrote that we were
roommates
at the time and we wrote the script
together and then we went to try to get
it made with each of us in the lead
roles like we basically I done this
cowboy movie that Tommy Lee Jones
directed and I played Matt Damon's
little brother and this was I was 18 and
we were in the middle of West Texas
Alpine Texas population like 32 and so
Matt Damon had to hang out with me
because otherwise I just be sitting in
my motel 6 by myself and he's too nice a
guy for that so I got that pal around
with this guy who is you know every free
moment was working on this script with
his buddy
you know like over the phone they were
exchanging faxes and stuff and I got to
read an early draft of Good Will Hunting
and I'm like you know this guy's great
like this is what I want to do I want to
write my own stuff just like Matt's
doing it so I started working on a
script and you know my best buddy and I
collaborated and so we finished this
movie and then we wanted to get it made
and we ended up attaching this director
and then IFC came in I guess bought the
script for like a dollar
you know something like that like
literally like here's a dollar we now
own the scrip baba and but I've seen
didn't want me to act in it they wanted
a bigger name so I agreed to take a
smaller part and they brought in this
little-known action and Joseph
gordon-levitt to play my part I mean if
you're going to be replaced by somebody
you really wanted to be Joseph
gordon-levitt but he did a great job
saying anyways that was the first one
and it was dumb look like I still don't
know how that movie came together
it's like Mike's manager also
represented this director who had ties
with a distribution deal and pulled the
financing together in some way but but
that was it and then we went to Sundance
in that movie so not overnight but
seemingly I went from you know guy from
commercials and the voice of Peter Pan
who's now a screenwriter at Sundance and
yeah that was it and then I went
straight from that to like writing for
other people on getting hired to do you
know touch up some punch ups and you
know make things work how many
screenplays would you say you've written
total whether they've been sold or
whether they're floating out there well
if you don't count the ones I wrote in
my childhood I wrote a really great
movie called the star team which is in
no way derivative of Star Wars but it
might be a little bit but like I started
writing scripts when I was a kid and I
would you know go to shoot them and get
about halfway through and lose interest
but as an adult as since manic I've
probably written jeez 30 40 probably 40
something like that that sounds right
okay hi I mean there's been months where
I've written a script in 15 days because
that's what was required in the job you
know and then I have had scripts that
took me three years to get through so
always a depending on what it is and
what the job is and most of these came
from relationships I mean it seems like
you knew someone who knew someone and
and that's how some yeah I mean I
basically uh cheese which when we got
distribution we were
working with this producer named Steven
LaRue Steven LaRue for outside sales
Steven Arun knew this producer named
Mike Elliot Mike Kelly had hired - me -
no Mike Elliot bought a script for me
called peach and then hired me to write
and like you know that's how it happens
actually like I'll do something or
someone will buy something or option
something and then say well can you fix
this script for me and that's really how
it works so I have like a handful of
creatives who have me on speed dial you
know and like I'm happy to jump in and
you know fix their scripts so they've
had a lot of writers ask us you know if
I'm coming to LA from either overseas or
another state how do I get these
contacts it sounds like almost by maybe
even the acting world it sounds like
that you built this creative yeah
rolodex
I know Road I'm really dating myself
without knowing I know what I thought I
said yeah yeah I mean you know in this
there's this my career is so strange
like I am NOT the archetypal I've got
I'm a writer I'm with CAA and CA gets me
the meetings and I come in and pitch
it's like that's never really been how
my career works on any level you know
it's like the the lead roles I've gotten
in films have been phone calls you know
they've not been auditions I the
auditions are the smaller things that
are you know peppered in to my resume
but like the things that changed where I
was in my career we're all always phone
calls always like plan I want you to do
this thing point well and I wrote this
part for you you know and the same thing
with writing like the stuff the the best
bang jobs the jobs that have moved me
into a higher echelon have always been
like okay this guy's going to call you
in five minutes he's a good friend of
mine I told them that you're great don't
blow the interview get the job and I get
the job you know it's I mean it's all
who you know is what they say but I
think in my career it's more than it is
in most people I don't know why would
you say though that I'm a writer should
even take
well I mean it sounds like such a
traditional route you know get an agent
do all you know you're talking about
antiquated before with distribution
right so it sounds like because you knew
a bunch of creative people and you were
also acting and doing auditions and all
that that it really helped to form these
people that would call you because they
knew they could trust you and that's not
an easy thing here so for someone that's
new coming here as a as a writer what
would you recommend because we get a lot
of questions like that we don't always
know what to tell ya I mean I don't know
like I've never had any luck with the
whole like sending a cover letter or
like you know here's a pitch of my
script every agent I've ever gotten has
been through a connection you know so I
think it's about getting into that world
in whatever way that you can if it was
an actor I would be like take acting
classes you know join a theater company
I think it's not different with writers
I'm just not sure exactly what that
organization is you know like there are
clubs there are you know the blacklist
has this you know website that you can
become a member of send your scripts and
they'll they'll read it and give notes
and stuff like that but like be a writer
you know tell people you're a writer go
to places where writers go you know what
I mean I mean they're great things the
WGA offers these amazing things now a
lot of people can't get in if they're
not WGA but there are things that you
can go and buy tickets to and go to
places that you know successful writers
go and meet those people because those
are the people that can help you yeah
sun festivals are a good idea - oh
that's a great idea that's true I mean
for you you're an actor and a director
and it sounds like you really get energy
from being around people but I know a
lot of writers are more hermit like yeah
so that's a problem I mean yeah and I
like I dig that but like that's tough
because you're not gonna make any
contacts being hermit like you know it's
just like the the writing like I want
candles and wine before I write but I
also have to get the script done so like
like you know and they're all so there
are tons of competitions that festivals
run or writing festivals so you went a
couple of those Awards that can get you
some nice intros you know I have friends
that have had some success with
you